ist der Bundespräsident Frank-Walter
Steinmeier
wie sich Dinge verändern und wie man in
dieser Veränderung das Richtige findet
darüber schreibt einen Region in seinem
jüngsten Roman Lektionen
Region erzählt darin die Geschichte von
Roland Beins dessen Leben untrennbar mit
einschneidenden Ereignissen der
Zeitgeschichte verbunden ist man reist
mit Roland banks durch die Jahrzehnte
immer auf der Suche nach der Antwort auf
die große Frage
wie geht man mit jenen Veränderungen um
die man nicht in der Hand hat
und die doch das eigene Leben prägen
liebe Gäste herzlich willkommen im
Schloss ist mir eine große persönliche
Freude
und eine große Ehre ihre majestätten
King Charles und Queen Konzert Camilla
heute anlässlich ihres ersten
Staatsbesuchs als Königspaar in
Deutschland begrüßen zu dürfen
und so wie ein Region seinen
Hauptdarsteller durch die Jahrzehnte
Reisen lässt
möchte ich heute Abend mit ihnen über
die großen Fragen der deutsch-britischen
Beziehungen sprechen über Kontinuität in
der Veränderung
über Umbrüche über Neuanfang
heute ist der 29 März
neben diesem Tag vor sechs Jahren
reichte die britische Regierung ihr
austrittsgesuch bei der Europäischen
Union
ich sage Ihnen das ganz offen für mich
persönlich war das ein trauriger Tag und
so ging es vielen hierzulande nicht
wenige befürchteten damals
Deutsche und Briten könnten sich über
diesen brexit verlieren
aber meine Damen und Herren das war
nicht der Fall
zu stark sind inzwischen die
Verbindungen zwischen unseren Ländern
zu eng die Freundschaften zwischen den
Menschen
zu kostbar das Werk der Versöhnung nach
zwei Weltkriegen
unsere Partnerschaft sie ist
Jahrhunderte lang gewachsen die
fortschrittlichen Ideen der Magna Kater
und den Bildern
der Einfluss großer Denker wie David
Hume und Thomas
die Musik von Georg Friedrich Händel
oder den Beatles
seit jeher sind unsere Beziehungen von
engen menschlichen Bindungen von
gegenseitiger Inspiration geprägt
auch der Fußball war eine englische
Verbindung eine englische Erfindung die
sich die Deutschen nur allzu gerne
abgeschaut haben
auch wenn zwischen uns nicht jedes Spiel
ein Freundschaftsspiel ist
es ist gut dass Deutsche und Briten
Realitäten heute
allenfalls auf dem Fußballplatz
austragen
meine Damen und Herren
heute stehen unsere Länder als
unverzichtbare Partner in fast allen
denkbaren Bereichen zusammen
im Bewusstsein unserer Vergangenheit
aber voller Zuversicht
was die Zukunft angeht so sagten sie es
mal steht so sagten sie es bei ihrem
letzten Besuch hier in Berlin im
Deutschen Bundestag vor etwas mehr als
zwei Jahren
nichts zeigt diese Verbindung so
deutlich
so festlich wie Ihr Besuch in
Deutschland Majestät auf ihrer
allerersten Auslandsreise als neuer
König überhaupt dieser
hochsymbolische Besuch
ist eine wirklich große persönliche
Geste ihrerseits
und dafür danke ich Ihnen dafür danken
alle hier im Saal Ihnen von Herzen
herzlichen Dank dafür
[Applaus]
meine Damen und Herren am 29 März 2017
begann der Austritt des Vereinigten
Königreichs aus der Europäischen Union
heute
genau sechs Jahre später
schlagen wir ein neues Kapitel wir
schauen unter veränderten Bedingungen
und doch gemeinsam nach vorne was auch
immer vor uns liegt ich weiß unsere
deutsch-britische Freundschaft bleibt
wichtig sie bleibt stark aber friendship
ist important
wie tief unsere Verbindung ist spüren
wir gerade in diesen Zeiten der
russische Überfall auf die Ukraine
der erste Angriffskrieg auf ein
Nachbarland innerhalb Europas seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg
was hat Erinnerungen an die schlimmsten
Zeiten auf unserem Kontinent wieder
aufleben lassen
aber Putins brutales Kalkül ist eben
nicht aufgegangen er hat Europas
Demokratien nicht auseinandertreiben
können wir die Verbündeten in der NATO
vereinigte Königreiche und die EU stehen
enger zusammen den je
die helfen den angegriffen in dem Kampf
für ihre Freiheit und ihre
Unabhängigkeit morgen werden wir in
Tegel ein ankunftszentrum für
ukrainische geflüchtete besuchen als
Zeichen unserer Solidarität ja und auch
als Zeichen der Dankbarkeit für die
große Hilfsbereitschaft und die
Anteilnahme die die Menschen in unseren
Ländern zeigen
Deutschland
das Vereinigte Königreich sind heute
auch militärisch die beiden größten
Unterstützer der Ukraine in Europa
morgen werden wir
gemeinsam mit dem deutsch-britischen
Bataillon in Brandenburg zusammentreffen
und erst vor wenigen Tagen habe ich in
Estland deutsche und britische Soldaten
besucht die von Estland aus gemeinsam
den Luftraum über dem bündnisgebiet der
NATO sicher
gemeinsam schützen sie die Ostflanke
gemeinsam schützen Sie unser
bündnisgebiet Seite an Seite Zeit bei
Zeit oder besser gesagt
[Musik]
meine Damen und Herren gerade nach dem
furchtbaren Unfall
das deutsche in zwei Weltkriegen über
den Kontinent gebracht haben
[Musik]
ist alles das keine
Selbstverständlichkeit ich weiß noch
ich weiß noch wie tief bewegt ich war
2018 als erster deutscher
Bundespräsident an der offiziellen
britischen Gedenkveranstaltung zum Ende
des Ersten Weltkriegs in London
teilnehmen zu dürfen
sogar im Gedenkgottesdienst investments
und es hat mir viel bedeutet dass sie
Majestät
im November 2020 als erstes Mitglied der
britischen Königsfamilie
beim Gedenken zum Volkstrauertag
im Deutschen Bundestag dabei waren und
gesprochen haben
übermorgen am Freitag werden wir
gemeinsam in Hamburg der Bombardierung
der Stadt im Jahr 1943 gedenken 80 Jahre
nach dem Bomben Terror deutscher
Kampfflugzeuge gegen britische Städte
welch große Geste der Versöhnung
aus Feinden von einst sind enge Freunde
geworden
eure Majestät das Werk der Versöhnung
die tiefe Freundschaft zwischen unseren
Völkern haben wir auch Ihnen und ihre
Familie zu verdanken die Familie Winzer
ihre Eltern allen voran ihre Mutter die
von uns allen zutiefst bewunderte und
hochverehrte Königin Elisabeth II er die
besondere Verbindung zu unserem Land nie
abreißen lassen immer wieder aufs Neue
gepflegt
so wie sie es auch heute tun ihre
Familie steht für Kontinuität
für Stabilität
gerade auch in Zeiten der Veränderung
und der Neuanfänge
magistic sie haben
bei unzähligen Gelegenheiten als
Botschafter für Aussöhnung für die
Freundschaft zwischen unseren Nationen
ihre Mutter unterstützt zu Deutschland
haben Sie auch persönlich eine enge
Beziehung ein Besuch bei Verwandten
führte sie
1962 das erste Mal hierher
gerade 13 Jahre waren sie damals alt und
sie bedarbe traten sie den deutschen
Boden ganz ohne offiziellen Empfang
ohne Presse ohne Fotografen und doch
gibt es davon ein bezauberndes Foto ein
Schnappschuss ein Schnappschuss der sie
zusammen mit ihrem Vater Prinz Philip
bei ihrer Ankunft damals auf dem
Flughafen in Frankfurt sein ein junger
Journalist
damals noch Praktikant hat das Bild auf
dem Rollfeld aufgenommen
majestätisches ist mir eine persönliche
Freude Ihnen gleich dieses Foto als
Erinnerung an diesen
besonderen Moment nach 61 Jahren als
Zeichen der langjährigen Verbundenheit
zu unserem Land
schenken zu dürfen und da das kleine
Bild nicht alle sehen haben wir es hier
einmal groß aufgezogen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe es nicht selbst nachgezählt
Majestät aber inzwischen waren sie über
40 mal in unserem Land als Prinz Charles
nun heißen wir Sie wieder herzlich
Willkommen zu ihrem ersten Staatsbesuch
als königsschals der sechste mai der Tag
ihrer Krönung steht für einen Neuanfang
und natürlich auch für Kontinuität
für Sie persönlich steht er für neue und
noch größere Verantwortung für die
Britinnen und Briten steht er für eine
neue Periode ihrer Monarchie
für uns hingegen und für die Beziehungen
zwischen unseren Ländern steht der für
große Kontinuität wir knüpfen an an
unsere jahrhundertelange Partnerschaft
an die Freundschaft zwischen Deutschen
und Briten und verehrte Majestät an
Ihren persönlichen Einsatz für die
Beziehungen zwischen unseren beiden
Ländern
dass sie mit ihrer Frau Queen konnte
Kamille noch vor ihrer Krönung nach
Deutschland reisen ist zu verstehen ist
auch eine starke europäische Geste sie
bedeutet mir
sie bedeutet uns Deutschen sehr viel und
wie viel davon konnten sie sich heute
Nachmittag vor dem Brandenburger Tor
glaube ich schon ganz gut überzeugen
begeisterte Berlinerinnen und Berliner
viele Gäste aus ganz Deutschland die den
Wert Ihres Besuches wirklich zu schätzen
wissen und der Tag ihrer Krönung er wird
ein weiterer guter Tag für die
deutsch-britischen Beziehungen sein
meine Damen und Herren
wir sind nicht das was uns widerfährt
sondern das
was wir daraus machen das ist die große
Lektion der Lektionen von einen Regionen
zu rasant die Veränderungen auch sind
wir stehen ihnen nicht machtlos
gegenüber wenn wir zusammenstehen
gelingt uns jeder Neuanfang und darum
möchte ich nochmals ganz herzlich meinen
großen Dank für Ihren Besuch ausdrücken
ihre majestätten gerade
auch als Zeichen dieses zusammenstehens
ich freue mich sehr auf die kommenden
Tage und die zahlreichen Gelegenheiten
die wir in diesen drei Tagen ihre
Staatsbesuchs zum Austausch miteinander
haben werden und nun möchte ich Sie
bitten alle miteinander
das Glas zu erheben mit mir auf die
Gesundheit ihrer Majestäten King Charles
und Queen Konzert Camilla anzustoßen und
auf ihr wohl liebe Gäste auf die
Freundschaft zwischen unseren beiden
Ländern zum Wohl und Brust
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Bundespräsident
ich weiß nicht wie ich Ihnen für Ihre
überaus freundlichen Worte und für ihre
unvergessliche Gastfreundschaft in
diesem festlichen Rahmen danken soll
es ist wunderbar heute Abend in so
größere Gesellschaft zu sein
und es ist schön von Ihnen dass
Sie gekommen sind und mich nicht mit
einem Dinner for one
alleine lassen
meine Frau und sich sind tief gerührt
die hässlich wir in Deutschland
empfangen würden
genau wie bei jedem unsere führenden
Besucher in diesem ganz besonderen Land
ich habe festgestellt dass ich
tatsächlich mehr als 40 Mal in
Deutschland gewesen bin
darin zeigt sich natürlich wie wichtig
mir unsere Beziehungen sind aber auch so
fürchte ich wie lange es mich schön gibt
an jeden dieser Besucher habe ich
Erinnerungen an die ich sehr gerne
zurückdenke
wunderbaren Freundschaften die sie und
Frau Büdenbender meiner Frau und mir
gegenüber gezeigt haben während unseres
letzten Besuches im Jahre 2019 und 2020
ich denke da an sehr gern zurück und ich
denke auch sehr gerne an die Zeit als
wir meine Frau und ich noch bayerische
Würste Essen auf einem Markt in Bayern
und dort tatsächlich auch Bier trinken
und Walzer tanzen im Hofbräuhaus ich
glaube ich kann auch verstehen warum der
englische Mönch Bonifatius ähm der ja in
Deutschland gepredigt hat ein großer
Anhänger des Bauwesens war
ich erinnere mich insbesondere daran wie
viel ich von meinen vielen Besuchern in
den vielen daran gelernt habe über
organische beziehungsweise ökologische
Landwirtschaft und ich bin da auch sehr
dankbar für das große Fachwissen das
deutsche das ist mir erlaubt hat für
meine eigenen
landwirtschaftlichen Unternehmungen zu
optimieren ich glaube wir können auch
viel lernen von dem was Goethe in Dorf
deutsch gesagt hat die erhabene Sprache
der Natur
in all diesen Jahren und auf so viele
Art und Weise war ich immer wieder
tatsächlich beeindruckt von der
Freundschaft zwischen unseren beiden
Nationen und der Vitalität unserer
Partnerschaft in so vielen
unterschiedlichen Bereichen
das ist deine Freundschaft herr
Präsident die an der auch meiner Mutter
der Königin Elisabeth sehr gelegen war
und ihr kam es sehr darauf an dass die
Beziehungen zwischen Deutschland und den
Großbritannien gut waren ich darf Ihnen
auch noch einmal danken für die vielen
vielen Beileids Kundgebungen die wir von
so vielen vielen Menschen aus
Deutschland bekommen haben als meine
Mutter im vergangenen Jahr dahinter
steht
meine Damen und Herren
ihre Güte bedeutet für meine Familie und
für mich mehr als ich überhaupt sagen
könnte
die Beziehung zwischen Deutschland und
dem Vereinigten Königreich
ist auch für mich sehr sehr wichtig herr
Präsident
und ich bin heute
stärker überzeugte denn je dass das von
dauerhaftem Wert für uns alle ist das
bedeutet für uns so viel dass meine Frau
und ich jetzt nach Deutschland kommen
konnten bei diesem ersten Auslandsbesuch
werden meine Regentschaft
ich kann Ihnen nur versichern
das
in der Zeit die mir als König noch
gegeben sein wird ich alles unternehmen
werde um die Beziehungen zwischen uns
noch zu verstärken und zu vertiefen
dabei weiß ich dass ich dann auch die
großen
Anstrengungen so viele Menschen
unterstützen werde die so viel
beigetragen haben zu der Beziehung
zwischen dem Vereinigten Königreich und
Deutschland
wenn ich mich hier im Raum umschaue
heute Abend
dann sehe ich so viele talentierte und
engagierte Personen die tatsächlich auch
das verkörpern was unsere Beziehungen
ausmacht wir haben das Ingenieurwesen
die Technologie die Wissenschaften
Umwelt die Kunst das Bildungswesen und
noch so viel mehr
unsere beiden länderarbeiten zusammen um
die Gesundheit weltweit zu fördern um
Entwicklungsländern zu helfen zu
Wohlstand zu kommen und dann auch die
wichtige Reise auf dem Weg zur CO2
Neutralität gemeinsam zu begehen und
natürlich stehen wir Seite an Seite
im Schutz unserer demokratischen Werte
ist heute auch ganz klar wo wir an der
Seite der Ukraine stehen die sich
verteidigt die die Freiheit verteidigt
und die Souveränität angesichts der
unbegründeten Aggressionen und da möchte
ich auch noch einmal Deutschland ganz
herzlich danken für ihre großartige
Gastfreundschaft mit der Sie über eine
Million flüchtende aus der Ukraine
aufgenommen haben das
belegte ja die Großzügigkeit des Geistes
auch der deutschen
der Bundespräsident
Deutschland und das Vereinigte
Königreich haben ein großes Interesse an
der Zukunft des jeweils anderen Landes
unsere Beziehungen werden noch stärker
werden da waren bin ich fest überzeugt
wenn wir gemeinsam auf einer
nachhaltigere Zukunft in Wort stand und
Sicherheit hinarbeiten
möge die Esche die ich heute nicht nach
Mittag in ihrem schönen Garten gepflanzt
habe ein kleines Symbol für das Wachsen
und Blühen unsere Partnerschaft sein
ich hoffe von
ganzem Herzen dass meine Frau und ich
lange genug leben werden damit wir in
diese wunderbare Stadt
zurückkommen und sehen können
wie unsere Baum gewachsen ist und damit
wir weiter unseren Teil zu dieser
kostbaren Freundschaft zwischen unseren
beiden Ländern beitragen können
erheben Sie bitte mit mir das Glas
[Musik]
auf Sie Herr Bundespräsident
und Frau Büdenbender und auf eine
Freundschaft die nicht nur hässlich ist
sondern auch
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes nachhaltig
zum Wohl
[Musik]
anstoßen im Schloss Bellevue heute
beim feierlichen Starts bankkette zu
Ehren des Besuches von König Charles den
dritten seiner Frau Camila wir sehen
einige Gäste wir sehen dort wie Frank
Walter Steinmeier anstößt mit seinem
Gast dort am Ehrentisch und neben dem
König konnte man eben schon sehen sieht
man jetzt über die Schulter von Frank
Walter Steinmeier Angela Merkel
ja das war der feierliche Auftakt des
Essens und dieser feierliche Auftakt der
markiert auch den ersten Tag des
Staatsbesuches von den britischen
Monarchen ich möchte darüber reden mit
zwei Gästen die hier im Studio ist
Graham Lukas britischer Journalist
das ist ein ganz besonderer Besuch weil
Charles zum ersten Mal als noch
ungekrönter König aber immerhin sein Fuß
auf europäischen Boden setzt und dann
direkt nach Deutschland
ja also die die Frage ist dann natürlich
versteckt ob ich Monarchist bin oder
nicht
zumindest ich würde es gerne so
beantworten ich bin sehr froh dass wir
offensichtlich jetzt ein neues Kapitel
in den Beiler trial tragen Beziehungen
aufschlagen denn die Jahre seit dem
brexit seit dem Abstimmung 2016 die sind
nicht schön gewesen
die britische Regierung hat sich
gegenüber Europa auch gegenüber
Deutschland nicht wirklich
freundschaftlich Verhalten es gab vor
allen Dingen ähm was von Jean paulis
Johnson zu hören dass er im Grunde
genommen die Europäische Union überhaupt
nicht schätzt und er hatte es ja auch
schon mal mit der Mitte sowie Union
verglichen und so weiter und so weiter
also alles war extrem
populistisch gefärbt und das klang ja
auch bei Frau Trust ähnlich sie hatte
auch
Gesetzesentwurf auf den Weg gebracht was
letzten Endes den das austrittsabkommen
zerrissen hätte wäre dieses Gesetz
durchs Parlament gekommen
das waren alles Sachen die natürlich die
Beziehungen belastet haben und in diese
Zeit haben die Briten beobachten müssen
wie
die Wirtschaft gelitten hat unter dem
brexit man spricht von einem riesen
Verlust gerade im Handel zwischen
Großbritannien und Deutschland
Großbritannien ist nicht in den obersten
zehn Ländern in der Liste der 10
wichtigsten Handelspartner mehr also es
ist ein tieferschlag auch für die für
die Briten lassen sich gleich noch
weiter vertiefen ich möchte gerne
unseren zweiten gesprächsgast
hereinholen Professor Daniel
Historiker und Politikwissenschaftler an
der Universität Erlangen Nürnberg und
genau da begrüßen wir sie ja auch heute
abend Professor Gosse sie haben mir noch
größeren den weiteren Blick das auch
Historiker es würden Sie sagen dass die
sagen wir mal wenn wir die vergangenen
100 Jahre betrachten dass die britisch
europäischen Beziehungen einem
tatsächlich ein Tiefpunkt waren nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg und jetzt auch
tatsächlich wieder so ein bisschen
wieder geheilt werden
oh das ist eine große Frage weil das
würde eigentlich eine sehr lange und
komplexe und differenzierte Antwort
eigentlich erfordern
sicherlich hat es größte Tiefs und
tiefste Krisen gegeben sie haben den
Zweiten Weltkrieg genannt und danach
ging war da wieder aufstieg der
Verbesserung der Beziehung zwischen
Großbritannien und Deutschland natürlich
sehr mühevoll aber insgesamt auch recht
stetig
Deutschland hat natürlich mal abgesehen
von diesen dunklen Kapitel der deutschen
Geschichte auch seinen Weg gebraucht
seine Zeit gebraucht sich überhaupt im
Westen das gilt nicht nur für
Großbritannien sondern es gilt auch
natürlich für Frankreich und das gilt
auch für die USA sich diesen westlichen
Nationen anzunähern aber das ist glaube
ich in den letzten Jahren bestätigt
gelungen und natürlich haben dann diese
bilateralen Beziehung dabei auch immer
eine wichtige Rolle gespielt das waren
natürlich nicht nur die Staatsbesuche
sondern es gab natürlich auch die vielen
anderen Kooperationsformen auf den
unterschiedlichsten Ebenen von
wirtschaftserziehung von
wissenschaftlicher Kooperation und man
darf natürlich auch nicht vergessen ich
denke vor dem Hintergrund des Ukraine
Krieges wird auch die Sicherheit ein
zunehmendes Thema Europa Europäische
Union hat man ja vor allen Dingen in
ökonomischen
Dimensionen eigentlich gedacht aber die
sicherheitspolitischen Dimension dass
wir
Verbündete sind in der NATO und dass wir
auch in dieser Krise zusammenstehen
müssen das ist natürlich auch ein
wichtiges Hintergrundthema bei diesem
Besuch das heißt es geht nicht nur um
wieder die Vertiefung der
europäischen spielerdrachen ökonomischen
Beziehungen sondern es geht natürlich
auch um eine Bestätigung der
sicherheitsallianz nur wurde ja die von
beiden
sowohl von der Bundespräsidenten als
auch von dem König wurde ja eben gerade
bet ont dass die Beziehungen weiter
vertieft werden sollen sie werden schon
gut und wenn wir zusammen stehen sagte
der Frank Walter Steinmeier dann werden
wir vieles erreichen können dann gelingt
uns vieles ähnliches hat dann auch Prinz
Charles gesagt ähm wie wichtig sind denn
wenn Glas drauf halten tatsächlich das
zusammen gehen von Deutschland und
Großbritannien ist das was besonderes
das ist schon was besonderes weil sie
können sich vorstellen dass gerade in
Großbritannien nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg ist große Vorbehalte über ein
deutsche Wiederaufrüstung über eine
deutsche Bundeswehr über die
Militärmacht Deutschland gab und diese
Vorbehalte die waren auch noch zur Zeit
der Wiedervereinigung 1990/91 zu spüren
und inzwischen war es natürlich hier
ging es eher eine andere Richtung dass
man Sorge hatte Deutschland könnte
aufgrund der jüngerer pazifistische
Tradition eigentlich nicht sein wer
Beitrag leisten
dahinter stehen natürlich
Ängste über eine im Westen nach wie vor
manchmal anzufindende
vermutete Wankelmütigkeit auf deutscher
Seite ich meine man müsste jetzt das
Beziehungsgeflecht zwischen Deutschland
und Russland bzw hat Union mit ins Spiel
nehmen da hat Deutschland auch Russland
Sowjetunion nicht immer als potenzieller
Rivale wahrgenommen es gab auch
Phasen wo Deutschland glaubte zwischen
dem Westen und Russland sozusagen sich
als Makler aufspielen zu können es gab
natürlich auch noch die unselige
kurzfristige Allianz zwischen dem
Dritten Reich und der im stalinischen
Sowjetunion also von daher war man sich
immer nicht so ganz sicher wie steht
eigentlich Deutschland zu Russland und
man hat natürlich auch gesehen dass in
den letzten Jahren und da ist natürlich
jetzt auch die aktuelle
Besetzung in der deutschen Politik nicht
ganz sozusagen aus der Verantwortung
rauszunehmen dass man da auch die
russische Politik des russische Vorgehen
ja manche Dinge sicher nicht falsch
eingeschätzt hat das ist ein sehr
komplexes Bild
das haben wir jetzt kurz angetippt wir
haben Gelegenheit Professor Daniel
Gossel auch in den nächsten Tagen der
Staatsbesuch das eine oder andere noch
mal das Auge drauf zu werfen ich danke
Ihnen erst einmal herzlich für diese
Einschätzung an diesem heutigen Abend
und ich gehe noch mal zu Graham Lukas
und bin damit sozusagen in der Jetztzeit
noch mal an wir haben ja gerade schon
oder Sie haben gerade schon über den
brexit geredet ist König Charles III
jetzt der Misere der aktuellen Regierung
kann man das so verstehen der das wieder
heilen soll eben diese Verbindung kann
er sehr politisch agieren also ist auf
jeden Fall derjenige der für gute
Stimmung jetzt sorgen soll in den
bilateralen Beziehungen
geklappt heute das hat man ja schon
gesehen von der Stimmung beim Festakt
und bei dem Festessen also ich denke
schon dass die britischen Diplomaten
sehr zufrieden sind heute Abend aber
letzten Endes ist Charles kein
handelnder Politiker er hat ein ganz
klares Mandat für diesen Besuch von der
Regierung die Regierung möchte
versuchen den brexit hat etwas in den
Hintergrund zu schieben das ist nicht
mehr die bilateralen Beziehungen
dominiert wie in den letzten Jahren und
wir mussten jetzt einfach sehen welchen
Kurs die zu einer Regierung in Zukunft
auch einschlagen wird Sonax selber ist
ein brexit hier er wird davon nicht
lassen aber es gibt allgemeinen
Unterhauswahlen in zwei Jahren in
Großbritannien und im Moment in den
Meinungsumfragen zumindest stehen die
Chancen von kirstama und Labels sehr gut
und er ist fest davon überzeugt dass die
Beziehungen wesentlich besser werden
müssen zwischen Großbritannien und der
Europäischen Union und vor allen Dingen
mit Deutschland ja und wir werden sehen
wie sich das weiter entwickelt Lukas
herzlichen Dank auch für auch an sie für
ihre Einschätzung für den Besuch für die
Analyse der Besuch dauert ja noch ein
paar Tage an
ja so weiter unsere Berichterstattung
über diesen Teil des Besuches wie gesagt
morgen früh geht es weiter wir werden
das auch wieder live begleiten wenn er
König Charles in Berlin unterwegs ist
und jetzt können wir zurück in unsere
Dokumentation Spione im Tierreich
solange die Mutter schnell wieder
auftaucht ist alles in Ordnung
[Musik]
bei starker Strömung jedoch wird manchem
otterkind schon mal bange und
verschwinden drauflos
[Musik]
dann muss die Mutter zusehen dass Ihr
Säugling wieder trocken wird
erst mit drei Monaten dürfte das Fell so
wasserdicht sein wie das eines